hey y'all it's center couch here in this
tight tuesday video we're gonna be going
over
data science workflows with our studio
so i saw a comment asking me to do a
brief overview of you know using rstudio
and just the general data science
workflow and i think it's actually
kind of a common question when you're
working with rstudio
and doing our programming is like how do
we actually organize our files
you know when we're starting a new
project with our studio like how should
we even even approach it should we just
kind of just write random r scripts or
or
what should we really do so i figured
i'd kind of show you how i do it
um i've never really taken like a formal
course on like project management with
like data science i've always just kind
of just done it
but here are just some things i kind of
have picked up so generally if i'm
starting you know a project from scratch
i'll just do a new project
um and i'll just do it for a new
directory again
new project and in this case i'll just
call it like
new yes projects
so we can specify the the directory um
that we're going to build upon
you can also create a git repository and
you can also use in our environment with
this object
with this project um i don't really want
to do an r
environment uh with this project because
generally i'll just create it after i do
all my stuff
and i'll kind of take a snapshot of it
instead of having to create a new
environment
so i'm just going to do this
so it's going to pop us into a new
session
and we can see how we have a new folder
says that says new ds project
with a new ds project our project
file so if i actually open up
my file explorer and go to
my artwork and go to the new ds project
we can see we have our proj user file
a new and then our actual our project
file
so generally when i'm creating um uh
when i'm starting a new project i'll
actually start creating a few folders so
i'll create a data folder a scripts
folder
and a presentation presentation folder
um and that that's kind of what i
usually do with three folders um
sometimes i'll create a models folder if
i'm doing a bunch of modeling
but in general i'll try to try to do
data presentation and scripts uh it's
pretty self-explanatory i'll put my
scripts
in the scripts folder any like excel
files
that i'm going to be using or that i
just want to like export to like maybe
send it to someone i'll put in the data
folder
and also if i have like some rds files
that you know i where i did a lot of
like
computation that i want to kind of start
from there i'll put it in there
i'll also put some model objects too and
also some sql scripts too in the the
data folder if i if i want to sometimes
i'll supply i'll put them in the actual
scripts folder but
sometimes i switch them to the data and
then lastly i think it's always good to
think
to have to have a presentation folder
because like
most data science projects a business
people or just like
stakeholders in general they don't
really care about your scripts you know
they don't really care about your clean
you know functions that you wrote uh
they want to have some type of like
uh action or decision from your actual
analysis or from your project
so it's always good to you know keep it
more focused towards
a presentation and storytelling
standpoint so i always have a
presentation folder where
i put like rendered markdown documents
as like reports i want to like walk
through people uh
do a walkthrough with people you know
i'll write some powerpoints
i'll export some plots um to put into my
powerpoints and stuff like that
so generally i'll create three folders
and if we look right here we can see we
have
our three folders right here um i'll
i'll generally just kind of
go in to the folders from the files pane
and then i'll just say uh set as working
directory
and we have that one really useful thing
that i find
that i use a lot now since i do way more
organized
projects is obviously i use a tidy burst
but i also use the
here package and the here package
basically
finds like the the r project
associated with the project uh with the
project uh
you know the project instance or
whatever and it basically sets that root
directory
so you know a lot of times when we're
trying to like reference a different
sub folder it's kind of a pain to work
with especially in r
but with the here package if we just
call here it'll always go into our
you know our sub our main directory or
our main
folder area and then what we can do is
like load it in from
uh using like so if we're gonna like
read it in a data frame so it's like
read.csv
we just call here and then we can also
say data dash
like iris.csv
um so that way we can kind of say like
hey i want to use
we're in our new ds project i want to
reference the data folder
and i'll call you know the data folder
with the actual file from there so
instead of writing all this out oh we
can just call this and it looks a little
bit more cleaner
and just works much better than doing
like all the tildes and stuff like that
um with the you know with all that like
um file notation stuff that gets a
little complex
so i generally will use the here uh
uh function to do that
so a lot of times when i'm doing um ds
stuff
data science stuff i generally do a lot
of markdown documents
um in this case i just do a generic um
markdown like that um sometimes i'll do
i'll change the outputs so like render
towards like a page thing and stuff like
that
um so if you want to do like a library
i'll just do it reverse and then i
if i want to do like the iris data set
or i'm like looking at a data set i can
do
i also will do a r markdown like page
table and that way oops i'll just say uh
i'm going to call this like eda right
there
so in that case we can actually go
through and what i'll generally do is
like oh
i'll knit it as an html file
um so let's see if they'll net so it's
going to knit and know me
right so then we have this file right
here and we have this page table
that we can kind of scroll through when
i'm like you know running through
uh when i'm meeting with people and i
want to kind of like run through my
analysis and kind of get
you know some feedback from it um and
stuff like that
um there's also ways to basically change
your
um your uh
uh what's it called uh your arm markdown
files so you can also have
all these type of things so you can do
presentations outputs
in this case i sometimes i'll add like a
table of contents and stuff like that
um but there's there's a bunch of other
things you can do so table of contents
uh and where that way you can do like uh
let me
do it so tlc is uh
was it true you'll see
uh float goes true
and that way you can say like uh big
data
analysis and say like iris
lm iris
so now that we can do like uh oops
people. length
it equals iris and then room
right so that way we can like knit it
oops
you'll see html document
oh there you go
uh what that but um yeah so
sometimes let me let's what's going on
i'll put html document um
what maybe oh
okay that'll do it okay there we go yeah
so you kind of have to do some uh
buffering like that but you know
sometimes i'll do that where you have a
table of contents with your analysis
and stuff like that which is pretty easy
to share and
so additionally you can again i'm going
to kind of
show like write csv the iris
and i'll say here data iris.csv
right and we can go into our actual
data and see iris.csv is right there
um one other thing that i can also show
you guys
oops
artwork new ds project there
is uh some basic commands
so again uh with a lot of times you have
a lot of code completion
so when it highlights that you can press
tab
and then write that out tab
again and you have that um
again i don't really use a lot of r
scripts that's when i do like more like
uh like quote-unquote production level
stuff where
uh i have to like i functionalize
everything and do that but let me show
you just some tricks with our markdown
um so one trick
with creating the actual code chunks is
ctrl
alt i and that'll basically put that
um you type in a tidy verse
and you know if you press ctrl enter
it'll do it'll run that that line
but if we also run um you know if we do
ctrl shift
enter it'll run the entire code chunk
and then what you can do is um you know
you can kind of scroll down and
press control alt i again if you do
control alt i
in it it'll exit out and make another
code chunk like that
so additionally what we can do is you
know if we have
a spot that we want to go to or just run
the entire script
uh you can just run like all chunks
below all chunks above
stuff like that there's a few things too
that are pretty useful with our markdown
is that you can actually change the
language
of the um of the code
throughout the actual document so you
know if i want to write
a sql query i can write this as sql
and then i can do my select star from
like table
right and that'll return a thousand rows
from the actual sql query just as a
preview
and then we can also do is output dot
var is equal to
you know df um one thing you have to do
is specify the connection so connection
equals
con con in this case we don't actually
have a specific connection so it's
something where
um you know uh oops i think it's
um so it's something where you kind of
have to
um you know actually explicitly say your
your
um sql connection through a db the dbi
or odbc package um so those are
just some quick things um again with
pipes
um control shift m to make your
mag like magniture or magic
tag reader or yeah yeah the mag reader
or i don't
mag retur um package where you just do
ctrl shift m
and that'll just kind of um type it out
for you
um with a space so you can easily type
in like iris
um select you know species
and and do that um to get out of
like when you call a function so like
select
uh species right obviously you can do
the tab and then to get out of
those parentheses you can just press you
know the right parenthesis and you get
out of it
control shift m you you do a pipe
enter i put again um what you want to do
and stuff like that so that's that's a
pretty quick
thing just some helpful things we can
look at uh when we're doing our
uh our our coding you can also look at
the environment stuff so in this case
we're going to have our files if we want
to like
import a file um and kind of do a more
like uh
user interface we can just do like
import the file we can name it
we have all these little default
configurations and you can import it
right
like that um but it again i wouldn't do
it like that i would
if anything i would probably just copy
this stuff right which i believe you can
copy
like that and then paste it
so that way you know if someone were to
look at your
markdown document they would actually
know where you're getting that file you
know what that file is actually called
stuff like that okay
um let's see what else can we do there
are a few
things that i've been using a little bit
more so right now i've been doing a
some package development just for like
internal use
um a lot of times what we wanted what i
want need to do is basically reference
the functions that i'm writing so a
common thing that i've been doing is
doing the control dots or control period
and this is the go to file or function
so i can do like iris
dot csv and kind of go to that file or
like if i want to like go to my eda or
markdown
i can go there and it'll kind of uh put
me into that area
okay here there
okay um another thing i guess
is is somewhat useful actually let me
pull up a our markdown document
um our markdown is uh
sometimes we want to look at a bunch of
plots or
a plot that doesn't really fit
in our uh
our you know our code chunks so let me
just do this
color is equal to species
okay so say we have this plot um and we
want to kind of like actually zoom in
onto it
um one thing we can do is just show in a
new window
um again i i don't really
see a lot of people doing like that they
kind of just view it so it kind of like
auto scales like that and we can kind of
just view it from here and identify um
useful things like that
so yeah and there's obviously code
folding and stuff like that too
um additionally if we look at the the
environment pane we can kind of look at
you know each you know variable so we
have this data frame it'll give us some
of the metadata
some some little examples essentially
it's like doing a i think what is it a
a glimpse of iris right so it's just
doing that
but if we we can click on it too and
kind of go through with
it as like essentially in a kind of like
a table
format uh you can do a full screen
you can do some filters show it's a
little distribution of it
um you can i guess filter i guess one
two
like two right you filter it
stuff like that and also sort it again i
don't really do that too much
um i'd rather just code it out um but
um i also think that it's not always
you know you can never go wrong just
viewing the data as a whole because
sometimes you can see weird um like row
level
index inconsistencies you know with like
you know maybe it's just a period of
rows
or entered in wrong so that it's always
something you can kind of consider
looking at
but yeah um this is this was basically a
pretty straightforward overview i think
what's really great about
rcu just as a whole is that you know
with our there's really no other
alternatives besides our studio and
maybe vs code
and what's really good about our studio
is
it's you know kind of created by people
uh who are
you know part of the tigers team so i
don't think it's
like i think it's a very unique thing
that
this these people offer and the data
science community so
you know with our studio tidy verse um
tidy models like they're all integrated
very well together
whereas like you're never gonna really
think of someone who like in
who writes in python where they have so
many um
uh uh so many other things that we can
do like
you know pie charm uh vs code
atom and you know none of the the no
those types of people
like none of the people on the pycharm
team are like you know developing
pandas as well um so i think that's why
our studio and our users definitely have
an advantage
with like the community and like the
product oriented data science products
um so um it's really nice to basically
have these types of features in our
studio
and what's also great is there's always
new add-ins to
it i haven't even gone over jobs which i
don't really use since i use more cron
jobs
um but it's always something that's
pretty useful and
hopefully these you know pretty basic
ideas from our studio can give some
beginners
a start into their own projects so with
that being said i'll see you guys next
week and tidy on